how many thomas kane books have you
written
three novels and four novellas
uh two of those novellas i co-wrote
actually with another author
uh and there's a fourth book uh that has
not been published yet
that's with an agent who uh you i think
you asked about this before but he's
considering you know he's shopping
around we're considering maybe signing
with a publisher
and seeing you know what that might mean
and what what might be out there in that
avenue
so what is that four or four it's about
eight eight thomas can books
and why haven't you tired of this
character yet
um i don't know i mean i you know i
think
i think
part of it i think is because i did keep
his past mysterious
so there's always something else to
reveal you know like i think if i had
one of the things i wanted to avoid was
that i saw in a lot of thrillers
i call like the resume you know where
they'll be like oh we're gonna bring in
this guy these ex-special forces and he
served five years in libya and you know
they kind of go down as
the whole thing and to me that kind of
takes the mysticism
out takes something away from it because
i sort of feel like well
if the only thing that's special about
him is that he's a navy seal who did
these things that any navy seal did
those things is the same you know it's
sort of so i i wanted to kind of avoid
filling in like every little detail and
and by doing that
i think it allows me to kind of find new
angles and new things that
you know i find interesting about him
because there is a big
black space you know in the background
so his
his background is is a mystery all we
know is that he was betrayed
at a certain point in his life but is he
a mystery to himself
or you don't go that far into his
thought well i you know i try to go
a little bit into his thoughts but not
too much because i feel like in fact i
originally when i first
conceived the series one thing i did
change was i originally was going to
write at first person
where you would hear his thoughts and i
realized i was like well
if i do that then i feel like i'm giving
too much away because you're always
going to know
you know what he's thinking so a lot of
time so i switched it to third person
and a lot of times when someone asks him
a direct you know really probing
question i'll have him just like look at
the person and not answer
and i try to let the reader kind of
project what they think the answer might
be
you know onto it so i really do make a
concerted effort to
as much without you know without
sacrificing
character and making him someone
believable and someone you can invest
yourself in i'd make a concerted effort
to keep as
much of him in the dark as possible you
know so that
because i think that that allows the
reader to inject a little of themselves
and their opinions and their beliefs you
know into his character
why is he doing this you know sort of
like as an
example in that first the first book
tokyo black he's uh
he is sort of driven to help this girl
and he's it's never really explained why
you know he sees a picture of her
and he just kind of from the very
beginning is
inclined to help this girl and i
remember the editor kept saying you know
i don't understand like why does he want
to help this girl so much why do you
want to help this girl so much
and to me maybe this was wrong but i
just felt like if i went and spelled it
out that would sort of
cheapen it you know i was like i don't
know he just feels this compulsion you
know
but by leaving it open that's what i
made the novella
about so in the novella that lot you
know that i gave away for free
it's sort of outlined this experience
and i don't directly connect the dots
but you could read the novel and say oh
well maybe that's why he might be
inclined to help this
person because here in this story he
didn't help a person
in a similar predicament and this is
what happened you know so
you could make that connection or not
you know so that's sort of the
way i try to handle that when you write
a spy thriller does the protagonist
really change
it's tricky you know i i don't think the
protagonist has to change
per se but i do think
some i think there's two ways you can go
and i've done both i think they can
change like in one area or in some area
or the world around them can change um i
think
you know like a character like james
bond for example changes very little
throughout the books but the world
around him
changes you know he stops things from
happening or he
i mean really most heroic fiction is
about reasserting the status quo right
like something
has gone awry and it's up to the air to
set things right
um and i think that's perfectly fine i
mean there's a million
books and movies that you know does
indiana jones really change you know
between those movies i i don't think he
does but they're perfectly entertaining
so i don't think it's a requirement
but i do think when you're writing it's
certainly more interesting
on the writer's side and i think this
might kind of go down to like what
you're saying about the reader's
expectation and the writer's expectation
i don't think the reader
expects your hero to change necessarily
book to book
but as a writer i think it's more fun if
you can sort of inject a little bit of
change
and so that's why over the course of the
first three books like i mentioned in
the fourth book he's back to working
with the cia
and the course of those first three
books is sort of about that change about
him
slowly kind of coming in from the cold
and learning how to trust again and
you know kind of rebuilding his life in
essence
and to coming in from the cold so from
being sort of this outlier this like
fringe
character and now being in this
structured environment where he's
totally watched yeah probably has that
and also i think
sort of believing in himself you know
believing that he can actually make a
difference and do something good
you know because he starts off very
bitter and angry at himself like i said
for the things he's done in the past and
there's a part of him that honestly
believes like
if i get involved with these people i'm
just gonna make it worse for them you
know like just
nothing good comes from me you know i
mean and so i think he's gradually
kind of lifting himself out of that i
mean he sort of starts out
you know a little bit of kind of
self-pity you know i mean he's he's
living off the grid he's kind of
operating as a petty criminal and just
kind of surviving
and so there's sort of this theme in the
first book about you know surviving
versus living you know he's not really
living he's just
surviving um so little things like that
but i
but they're not drastic changes i mean
he's certainly
consistent you know throughout the four
books and i that to me that's enough to
keep it interesting for me and i don't
think the readers really want him to
you know suddenly you know wake up and
be a totally different person or have a
huge you know come to jesus kind of
thing i don't think that's what
readers of that genre looking for okay
true or false
question here all major characters have
strong motives
and that their own journeys aren't
always in alignment with any other
character
all right let's do let's break that up
into two so all
major characters have strong motives i
mean i don't i don't
i feel uncomfortable saying all anything
i mean like i said i don't think there's
rules and i'm sure
there's great stories that might not pop
into my head where they don't have
strong motives
uh maybe like
dazed and confused that's a great movie
i don't know i'd have to see it again
but i don't know if i'd say they have
really strong motives i think it's all
that movies almost about them sort of
finding a motive like by the time they
get to the end you know
um but i think that certainly
most characters tend to and and i think
it's
probably easier to construct a
compelling story around someone has a
really strong motive
versus someone who doesn't like for
example uh
close encounters the third kind you know
i mean that guy is
obsessed like his entire life revolves
around figuring out like what happened
and getting to this
point you know and he can't even explain
why but he's willing to give up
you know his family and his job and
everything like that
that i think it's i think it's easier to
construct that kind of story than
someone is just kind of ambling
along and then the second part is um
that their own journeys aren't always in
alignment with any other character
sure i'd say that's true i mean because
that's flexible right it says aren't
always so maybe they are but they
certainly don't have to be
how do you keep track of your characters
and all of their motives
you know i don't know i
i don't really have a hard time with it
i know some people make uh
you know charts like excel sheets like
if you read a lot of books on outlining
say to uh you know for each scene you
always want to write down like the main
character and what their goals are for
the scene
i find for whatever reason that just
isn't an issue for me
like i tend to know what the character's
motives are i just
maybe that's i don't know maybe that's
just how i kind of come up with the
scenes
from in the first place but i've never
really had a problem
with that like it's just sort of in my
head
how important is that first opening page
i think it's certainly important i think
people i don't know i mean i guess
it depends on your style i mean i think
some people really want that
amazing sentence that just hooks you
i'll be honest i don't tend to write
that way i don't tend to have that
usually i think my openings are more
kind of uh
setting a place and kind of drawing you
in you know
i think one way or the other you need to
interest a reader but i think there's
lots of different ways
of doing that so i think again you just
have to find what works for you
you know but i think if you read my
books i don't think you would like read
the first sentence of any of them and be
like that's an amazing first sentence
you know i think
that just isn't isn't my style okay so
it's not it was the best of times
but i know uh who is it uh lee child
says that he like spends days like he'll
rework the first sentence over and over
and over
you know to to get it to be just right i
don't know i
for me it's more about the mood i'm
establishing in that first page than
like you know
getting that sends that really pops
but you know everyone's different and
you have to find what stylistic touches
work for you
you